keep your mind flexible any challenge
you have think of all the possible ways
you can solve it or go about
accomplishing what you want to do and
figure out which one is the best
I find having mental flexibility helps
me all the time example that jumps to
mind this was about 20 years ago
something really important to me I was
flying across country I was going to JFK
Airport I was a little late I was
parking my car in the long term lot I
pulled in to the lot and a ticket was
supposed to come out of the machine
automatically but it got stuck inside I
heard the whirring sign I looked in and
saw you know the little horizontal bar
and my ticket is stuck in there the bar
won't go up meanwhile cars are piling up
or stocking stacking up behind me I
can't go into the lot I'm about to miss
my plane what do I do well I got out of
the car looked around and saw a paper
clip so I picked it up I twisted it
reached in poked it in that hole in the
machine hooked it on one of the holes of
the card extracted my ticket raced to
the airport and I literally got to the
plane as they were shutting the door so
I made my plane because of my puzzle
solving ability